- I'm great.
- You must commit to your own gift.
- Greatness
- You have to really commit.
- I aspire to be something greater.
- Hello, Believe Nation,
my name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and I believe
that entrepreneurs will solve all
of the world's major problems.
So, to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn how
you can commit to greatness.
And also, guys if you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it.
You might win a prize.
But also, when you write it down,
it's much more likely to stick
with yourself as well, enjoy.
(inspirational music)
- Now a lot of you all people
talk about The Black Mamba.
The Black Mamba, let
me tell you something.
When you talk about The Black Mamba,
you talk about practice, it's a must-have.
I watched this dude lose a game, a game.
I don't even know if it was the playoffs.
I think it was like a regular
game against the Miami Heat
in Miami, South Beach Florida.
I don't know if you've
ever been there before,
but it's, you want to go.
It's a nice place to just hang out.
Especially if you're on
the road playing ball.
It's a nice place after the game
to go get dinner, sit
on the beach, it's nice.
And I'm sure if you're NBA,
they probably got a VIP
section for them on the beach.
Now unfortunately, the
Lakers lost to the Miami Heat
because Black Mamba missed a
wide open shot in the corner.
Set shot, he missed it.
What he did for the next three, four hours
while everybody else was getting dressed
and going on the beach,
he sat there for hours
shooting the exact same shot
over and over and over and over.
Like he had never won a championship.
I'm like, now hold up.
Where everybody else at on the Lakers?
They need to be out there as a squad.
But the Black Mamba's out
there doing his thing like,
"I'm not on them, I messed up.
"I've got to practice."
And this is not a coached practice,
this is not, the organization
didn't call this one.
This was just flat out,
The Black Mamba was saying,
this is a must-have.
And where most of you go wrong,
you not even 4.0, and you not studying.
Like you not even 4.0 student.
Like you a two point, a two
five, a three something,
and you still not really
studying like that
because for you it's like,
it's not a must-have.
It blows my mind.
I work with professional athletes,
I work with D1 athletes
all over the world.
And when I look at Twitter and Instagram,
it blows my mind how dudes on Instagram,
I'm like, "Bruh, you have
not won a championship."
Like that's what you come here
for, to win a championship.
And so if you don't win a championship,
I don't even know why,
there's people broke,
I don't even know how you have enough time
to do a 30 second video, you broke.
How did you have time to do a video?
How did you have time
to do a dance routine
when you should be practicing?
You should be lifting weights,
you should be looking at film.
You said, not me, that you
want to win the tourney,
that you want to win it all,
that you want to go to the Final Four.
How do you want to go to the Final Four,
but your schedule don't
look like the Final Four?
What are you Tweeting
about when you broke?"
- I realized that to
have the level of success
that I want to have it's difficult
to spread it out and do multiple things.
You know, in order to be world-class,
and I made a decision, I
want to be world-class.
It takes such a desperate, obsessive focus
to excel on the level that
I want to make movies.
You know, Star Wars, when I was young,
I sat in the movie theater
and watched Star Wars,
and I just couldn't believe
that that movie made me feel
like that, just floored and
just stunned by the creativity.
And just, I'm realizing
that in order to move people
in that way, in order to
touch people in that way,
you really got to focus
with all of you fiber
and all of your heart, and
all of your creativity.
- Making the right decisions
is a one on one battle.
Whatever the majority
of the crowd's doing,
find your way doing the opposite.
And see nine times out of 10,
how right you turn out to be.
How many out here, show of hands,
how many out here have found
out a way to not waste time.
Show of hands.
So it's simple.
See God gives us a lot of things in life,
but it's a couple things he don't give us.
And time is something he gives no man.
That's the one thing, no matter
if you look at your watch,
I look at my watch,
you look at your clock,
I look at my clock,
you look at your phone,
I look at my phone.
Time slows down for no man.
So the question is, how much
time you going to waste?
I gave up on trying to
make money years ago.
I gave up on entertaining clubs years ago.
14 years since I even entered,
even thought about
taking a step in anything
that doesn't reflect
where I'm trying to go.
That's what you got to put in your head.
Every decision you make,
does this decision influence
where I'm ultimately trying to go?
Because if it does, you
got to get rid of it.
So these conversations
that I came to have today,
I could go all day, because I love sharing
the reason why people don't realize
what you got to give up to become great.
What sacrifices you got
to make to become great.
What promises you got to make
to yourself to become great.
Greatness ain't a thought process.
Greatness is a lifestyle.
It's what you live like.
It's what you get everyday and breathe.
- You know hard work pays.
I put in a hell of a lot of work
all throughout this buildup and the fight.
I pumped out more content that anybody.
More content than Fox,
more content than ESPN,
more content that BT Sport, more content
than everybody under my
glove, on my own channels.
You know what I mean?
I'm a mother (expletive) work horse
from all angles, not just in the gym,
but I'm building the media empire now,
and we've pumped out the content,
and I'm very proud of how it went.
We consistently, daily
movies I was releasing,
from like a month ago,
every single day.
Nobody's doing that, so.
I'm very proud of it, and
I'm very, the work pays.
Hard work pay, and we put
in the (expletive) work
and that's why I'm sitting at the top.
I put it all on the line,
I show up, I perform,
and I get the results from that.
- You know Shark Tank,
I do the show not because
they're great investments,
but I do the show because
it send the message
to kids 8-80 that the American
dream is alive and well.
You can watch the show and come to realize
that somebody out of Iowa
or the middle of nowhere
in Texas can start a company,
and turn it into something special.
And I think so many families
watch the show together
that's it's just, particularly
in this day and age
when so many people are
saying what's wrong with this,
and what's wrong with that,
and what's wrong with America,
it just really reinforces that somebody
with an idea who's willing
to go beyond just an idea
to a company phase, and really work,
something special can happen.
And just reinforcing that
is really important to me.
- And like I've said before,
we each have a gift,
but too many people miss
out because they refuse
to sign the lease on their gift.
You keep looking for it outside of you.
Stop. Sit with yourself.
What is it that you do the absolute best
with the least amount of effort?
That's your gift.
But if you are constantly
looking outside of yourself,
and you don't latch on to your gift,
you will never find your purpose.
If you want to succeed, you must commit
to your own gift and embrace it.
- A good fighter's not
necessarily the greatest fighter
that ever lived, it's
where do you want to go?
A good fighter just to be diligent
and committed, and disciplined.
Doing what you hate to do,
but do it like you love it.
Always testing yourself, and
forcing yourself to the limits.
If you know you love women,
then deny yourself that.
That's what success in general
is all about, sacrifice.
From my experience,
of any of the little
success I may have had,
just be willing to sacrifice.
Unfortunately, sometimes
you can't have fun
accomplishing your goals.
And when sometimes people
don't have the determination,
the will, and the
steadfastness, the tenacity,
they give in under the slightest struggle.
- Greatness is a different
definition to different people.
Greatness to me is (expletive) when I land
that (expletive) fakie half cab hill
on my skateboard or some (expletive).
Greatness is the (expletive) song
I recorded last week.
Somebody might not find that
great, but it's great to me.
And that's all that matters.
What the (expletive) I think, in my head.
As long as I like it,
that's all that matters.
Greatness to me is finally
getting my video on MTV.
It's on there now, and I'm (expletive)
I'm happy.
I finally got my (expletive)
on (expletive) MTV.
Some people might thing that's
selling out or whatever,
but I don't really give a (expletive).
That's (expletive) great
to me, I'm proud of myself.
I've been wanting that
since I was seven years old,
and I finally got that (expletive).
Hard work pays the (expletive) off.
- Martin Luther King tried
to commit suicide twice.
You guys see what I'm saying here?
JFK went through periods of deep illness.
Deeply, deeply ill where
people thought he would die.
These types of things, right?
Winston Churchill went through
deep, deep depressions.
So you can become one of those people,
doesn't mean you're going
to become one of them,
because I mean those guys are in their own
(expletive) universe,
but you can become somebody of great power
if you've gone though that
because you've been hardened.
Do you guys see what I mean here?
If you've been through that
kind of bull (expletive),
then if you've conditioned yourself
to pull yourself out
of something like that,
if the world gets all (expletive)
up, all the other people,
they're used to happiness.
They're like, "Whoa, happy." They're like,
"My happy world is falling apart.
"My happy world is falling apart."
(Expletive) gets all (expletive) up,
you're like, "It's all good baby."
You know, you don't care
because you're adjusted to it.
So you've taken conscious control.
Do you guys see what I mean?
Okay, so there's benefits.
Being a hard case newbie
means that you can be better
than any of the guys that had it easily.
It'll be harder to get, but you can excel
to a higher level than all the people
that were naturally
good, if you choose to.
But for you, it will be
a life of commitment.
In the same way that a guy
that wants to get kind of big
in the gym, if he's going
to be big in the gym
and he's a hard gainer little skinny dude,
he's going to have a
higher commitment level.
To get to that level,
you're going to have a
higher commitment level.
You're not going to get
to average as easily.
And sometimes even striving to stay
at average won't work for
you because you slip back,
so you have to really commit.
You have to take your foot
off the (expletive) parking break, man.
You have to burn the boats as they say,
And just go for it.
As a hard case newbie, if you do that
you can slowly build
those will power muscles,
slowly re-acclimate
your body to positivity,
build up friends, build up abundance
build an amazing situation for yourself,
and do amazing, amazing things.
- There's a lot of
people who get frustrated
who then say, "Enough is enough,
I'm going to do something."
And then the next day they wake up and
they're back to their old life.
They had this moment of
boldness, a moment of greatness
and they fall back into
repeated patterns and habits
and life just gets them down again
and they go back to their
job and their regular life.
How did you break that cycle?
this is actually the day I'm going to go
and do something bigger?
- I think it was just a
moment of enough is a enough.
I was sleeping on my sisters
couch for a couple of years
originally, and she had told me,
"Are you going to start paying rent?"
At about the year and a half mark.
(laughing)
Like, "when are you going
to start paying rent?"
Because I was just
eating her food for free
I was a slob, I didn't clean up
I was just taking
advantage of the situation.
And I was 24 years old or something
and I just remember being like,
"It's time for me to grow up
"and do something with my life."
I've sat here for a year and a half,
almost two years now,
depressed, miserable,
whatever I was doing, making excuses.
This isn't who I want to be.
I aspire to be something greater.
My parents didn't raise me to be this way.
I wanted to make myself proud.
I wanted to make my last name proud.
I wanted to make my family proud
and I wanted to be a symbol.
I think, you know, I've
always wanted to be a symbol
of inspiration, of possibilities.
From my sports days, I remember
the feeling after the games
when parents or fans, or
parents of other players
from other teams would
come up to me and say,
"Thank you for showing me what's possible.
"There was no way you were able
"to catch that ball, but
somehow you did that.
"It blew my mind.
"There was no way you
guys should have come back
"after how much you were down,
"and what you did blew me away."
I loved hearing that, and
seeing in other people
this spark of passion, this
excitement of possibility
for what they could create in their life.
And I wanted to be that
symbol of passion and vision,
and focus and commitment, towards my dream
to show other what's possible.
And I've never been the
best at anything I've done.
In sports, I was always the underdog,
I was never the biggest,
fastest, or strongest dog.
And I think I just wanted to
show people what's possible,
so that's what I'm still doing.
I'm just a kid from a small
town in Delaware, Ohio
who had a lot of emotional
turmoil inside growing up
and I'm trying to show
people what's possible
no matter where you come from.
- Thank you guys so much for watching,
I hope you enjoyed.
I'd love to know what did
you take from this video
that you're going to
immediately apply somehow
to your life or to your business.
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really excited to
see what you have to say.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you, I hope
you continue to believe
in yourself, and whatever
your one word is,
much love, I'll see you soon.